on retrouve jonathan walsh notre envoyé
spécial dans la région de kherson quelle
est la situation sur ce front
écoutez la position ukrainienne où je me
trouve en ce moment répond en réalité à
votre question il ya encore quelques
semaines et ici nous étions en première
ligne aujourd'hui ici c'est la deuxième
ligne des deux fronts des positions
ukrainienne nous sommes sur une position
d'artillerie juste à côté de moi se
trouve se trouve une des pièces
d'artillerie qui sont déployés sur le
terrain par le par cette unité de
l'armée ukrainienne avec laquelle nous
sommes aujourd'hui nous sommes au nord
de rennes cette ville qui a été prise il
y a quelques semaines par les forces
russes et les positions russes sont à 6
km à peu près de la position où nous
nous trouvons nous avons discuté un peu
de la situation sur le terrain certes
les forces ukrainiennes ont réussi à
contre attaquer sur certaines localités
ces dernières semaines et même ces
derniers jours ils ont repris quelques
villages aux russes mais ils nous ont
dit que cette cette contre attaque ne
devait pas être surestimée seuls
quelques localités ont été reprises et
ils nous disent aussi qu'en première
ligne à quelques kilomètres d'ici
l'intensité des combats elle n'a pas
diminué elle est toujours aussi forte
qu'au début du conflit enfin les
ukrainiens attendent toujours des
livraisons d'armes modernes de la part
des pays occidentaux
oui absolument c'est ce qu'on entend sur
sur toutes les lignes de front où nous
nous sommes rendus avec un marada
mehdaoui ces 10 derniers jours et puis
cette pièce d'artillerie que vous voyez
à côté de moi en fait elles datent de
l'ère soviétique elle date des années 70
et c'est une illustration assez
frappante du besoin d'armes de des
forces armées ukrainiennes des pièces
d'artillerie des armes automatiques qui
date de l'ère soviétique il y en a
beaucoup nous en avons vu beaucoup lors
de nos reportages avec camarades à
mehdaoui est ce que demandent les forces
ukrainienne aujourd'hui ce sont des
armes modernes capables leur permettant
de riposter face à la poussée russes il
s'agit notamment
déjà velin américain c'est lance
missiles anti chars modernes qui ont une
plus grande portée une plus grand force
de frappe que les lances missiles anti
char dont l'armée ukrainienne dispose il
s'agit aussi de systèmes de
lance-roquettes multiples voilà tous et
tous ces armements ultramoderne dont
disposent les pays de l'otan l'armée
ukrainienne on a en très petite quantité
et il ils attendent désespérément ses
armes modernes pour pouvoir distille
gagner la guerre merci beaucoup je
n'atteins walk on dit